POV you're brand new to web development
and you want to learn react.js most of
the tutorials and even chat GPT tell you
to use an official tool called create
react app but it's a trap if you use it
you already failed your react developer
admissions test and as punishment you
now need to go learn ember.js
bloggers and YouTubers have been warning
people against create react app for
quite a while but the discussion really
heated up with this pull request from
Theo suggesting the removal of this tool
from the react docs altogether Dan from
the react team responded with five
different potential options to salvage
the sinking ship but what's with all the
hostility in the first place the problem
with it is that it's slow in development
is a pain to set up with popular tools
like tailwind and typescript and most
importantly there are just tons of
better options to get started with react
and the modern ecosystem in today's
video we'll look at seven ways to create
a react app without create react app and
look at the trade-offs so you can choose
the optimal tool for the type of app
you're building the absolute easiest way
to experiment and start learning to
react or any front-end framework is with
an instant development environment like
stack Blitz or code sandbox these are
web-based tools that allow you to run
react in the browser without needing to
manually install a bunch of dependencies
on your system and deal with things like
module bundlers like you literally just
click a button and now you're building a
react app it also has the added benefit
of being easily shareable so you can
access it from any computer this Tech is
come a long way in the last couple years
and you can even run back end code like
node.js and next.js thanks to web
containers overall this is a great
choice for Learning and prototyping but
if you're building a serious app you'll
need a dedicated build tool to manage it
and this is where decision making gets
tricky the next tool we'll look at is
Veet which is enjoyed a meteoric rise to
the top of the JavaScript build tool
charts over the last year or two if
you're already familiar with create
react app vit is the closest thing to a
one-to-one replacement for it however
it's way faster in development because
it builds your application on Demand
with tools like native es modules and Es
build that just scale way better for big
projects and as of a few weeks ago you
can use swc instead of Babel which is a
much faster rust based compiler it uses
roll up for module bundling as opposed
to webpack and CRA it also has a
typescript template out of the box and
should support any modern libraries that
you want to use what's important to
understand though is that it provides a
starting point for building a single
page application unlike react rendering
Frameworks like nexjs it doesn't deal
with server-side rendering or routing at
least out of the box Veet does have a
low level API for Server rendering and
there are plugins that support it but
this would be a more advanced setup for
developers who really know what the hell
they're doing and don't want to use a
react rendering framework for whatever
reason if you want to learn more about
this I have a video on my second Channel
Beyond fireship about 10 different
rendering paradigms the bottom line is
that Veet is a great option when
building a single page application with
react but there's another awesome tool
called NX that can build Standalone
react apps along with some extra
features that you won't find in V and X
is a tool known for building mono repos
but its CLI can also build plain react
apps that have nothing to do with mono
repos what's cool about it is that when
you set up a new project you have the
option to choose your own bundler like V
to webpack or bundlers of the future
like RS pack which is a rust-based
replacement of webpack it's set up with
typescript by default and you can also
choose a CSS preprocessor its killer
features though are all about scaling
complexity like it does task caching and
can even distribute that cache on the
cloud which means when another team
member or continuous integration server
on the other side of the world builds
the app it'll use the computation in the
cache instead instead of doing the same
work over and over again and that can be
a game changer for large teams but even
if you're an independent developer NX
has other useful tools like generators
that can automatically add dependencies
like Tailwind or scaffold out the
boilerplate for components and libraries
then from there you can visualize how
all your code is related with the NX
graph command and finally when it comes
time to automate with continuous
integration and delivery you can easily
make that happen by generating a CI
workflow just choose a provider then it
writes all the boring and error-prone
configuration for you that's pretty cool
and NX can be used in other react
Frameworks as well but what if you want
more than just a single page application
well that's where react rendering
Frameworks AKA meta Frameworks come in
with the most popular option being xjs
the main difference when building a next
JS app is that you have a special direct
Reef like Pages or app that can
structure routing for a multi-page
application and Pages can be rendered on
the server to improve search engine
optimization and performance it also
does server-side data fetching with
react server components to build full
stack applications with minimal external
dependencies like here we're using async
await in a component that can run
universally both on the client and
server and it provides tons of other
features like image optimization and
middleware that you likely want on a
serious production project but next is
not the only game in town remix is a
similar framework that was recently
acquired by Shopify that provides many
of the same features like file system
based routing next in remix have been
competing over the last couple years
which is awesome for react developers
because now we have two excellent
rendering Frameworks to choose from the
biggest difference is related to data
fetching the xjs uses react server
components while remix does not both
Frameworks solve many of the same
problems but there are many subtle
differences in the developer experience
at the time of this video features like
nested layouts and streaming are in beta
in next.js while they're fully stable in
remix so it's one step ahead of the game
here when it comes to Innovation but yet
another react rendering framework to
think about is Gatsby it's not as hyped
up as it used to be but was just
acquired a couple days ago by netlify
originally it was popular for building
content heavy statically generated sites
but it also supports server side
rendering just like next JS and remix
the most striking difference is its
focus on graphql to provide a data layer
for your application it has this thing
called Walhalla content Hub that creates
a single graphql API for all of your
data sources that can be accessed with
zero configuration from a Gatsby front
end if you're looking to migrate a
content-driven app to react Gatsby has a
lot more Tools in place to make that
process happen faster it'll even ask you
which CMS you want to use during the
initial setup and will also add features
like markdown although another great
option for a Content heavy site is Astro
unlike all the other Frameworks we've
looked at Astro is not exclusive to
react it can also be used with spelled
View and solid or all these Frameworks
simultaneously react is most useful for
building highly interactive uis but in
most Frameworks react takes over the
entire Dom Astro on the other hand has
its own templating language for handling
the majority of your static content then
you can sprinkle in interactivity as
needed thanks to its Island's
architecture not only does that simplify
your code but it also results in huge
performance gains because in many cases
it eliminates the need to ship
JavaScript to the browser making your
website load faster it also just
released version 2.0 that has a new
feature called content collections where
actual markdown content adheres to a
schema allowing content heavy websites
to scale up safely and now you have
seven different ways to create a react
app without using Create react app I'm
not sure what the future holds for
create react app but if they go with
option 5 it'll turn into an app launcher
that'll point you to one of the
Frameworks I mentioned in this video or
maybe they'll go with my idea option 6
integrate generative AI into the tool
where you just tell it what you're
trying to build and it automatically
generates the starter project for you if
the react team doesn't do it I think
we'll see a tool like this by the end of
the year and finally I want to thank NX
for sponsoring this video they would
have been on the list without a
sponsorship but they also have an
awesome YouTube channel that you should
definitely be subscribed to thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one